hey I was going for us my name is whoa
Jesus Christ today we're gonna play the
best game ever made it I can't believe
I'm doing this I honestly cannot believe
I'm playing this game
Demi Lovato made a game
it's called Demi Lovato path to fame and
you bros won't shut up about me playing
it so uh to be honest I I'm kind of
curious she be honest I'm running out of
battery to to be honest I love Demi
didn't give me you what is her name
again uh here we go Debbie's birthday
jammies 15 wears an Aegis 20 we wanted
to keep this story open to read as I
thank you for being such a dear me
I'm a big fan all right I'm a good fan
all right so this is me I made that
character by the way I try to make it as
ugly as possible that is what I got hey
Holly how's Demi's birthday prank going
only 15 minutes ahead of schedule
knowing you a kid but you have no idea
how artists the press are breathing down
my neck
trying to guess what's blind think they
got any ideas not a bulb like the press
would give any about Demi Lovato
and her birthday okay I get to make a
choice here actually get to play get
Demi to the party totally how will I do
that what if I mess up how will I do
that I don't care I literally don't care
literally don't give a single this
game is great thank oh oh it just keeps
going huh
hey a slicker hey Jimmy oh I got a
play cool yeah what's up just getting
back from a reading session you know I'm
a writer now apparently Demi Lovato
wants us to know that she's a writer man
are you ever not working apparently Demi
Lovato was it wants us to think that
she's a really hard worker
ha ha ha ha ha ha I want to kill myself
I want to check her shopping
making my way downtown I'm trying to
kiss the wheel apparently oh god it's
dented from Dante's Inferno oh god what
the I knew I was gonna come
face-to-face with a Wolverine okay hey a
slicker is everything okay
why are we at the gym anyway I thought
we're we're going shopping
hey a slicker where are you going the
beach oh my god I can't I literally can
I'm sweating I literally can't why am I
playing I don't want it you know I give
up you win you win Demi Lovato I don't
understand why anyone wouldn't buy more
of these they're so good they're so good
I want to play more I'm just kidding
them I love you too Timmy I'm sorry um
settings let's contact support there's
literally there's no support for the
game
this is support for this game
ahahahahaha
how do I get refund I haven't paid
anything but my time I want my time back
so basically the whole game isn't even a
game it's just like a mod of another
game that's cool that's real cool Sam
Ashe liquor
are you having serious - heavy right now
- when we meet on street corner of first
year in college only thing missing is
you barreling into me with a monstrous
cup of coffee
flirting one a wine hey worked on me I
never liked that jacket anyway ah are
you free tonight
your plays are mine alright we're gonna
we're definitely gonna this is
our room what the is your doing
this is the flip my favorite game at my
favorite game of all time it's your best
friend what's your name Uranus what's up
I wonder where you were here's Uranus
your best friend I'm so childish do you
want to change how she looks no way she
looks great
are we going to the demi lovato concert
hey so these are the fans I go to Demi
Lovato concert she fainted huh alright
cool it's this whole game just like a
big ego boost for Demi Lovato
don't understand what is this what is
this wait we got fans because I sang why
am i singing
ah-ah-ah
wait I have to buy to meet Demi Lovato
and it'll cost me $2 $2 I think I'm good
but thank you like when the are we
gonna see God
ah thanks for watching this video I
can't believe you made it all the way
through what that was this
let's never play this again let's
make a promise right here let's make a
pact never to touch this game alright
first thank you for watching
I'll see you the next one stay awesome
we got a level pack - Oh a stamp well I
guess I'll just put just kidding